hello everyone and welcome back to our
broadcast of the 2023 national
championships we have one result in the
open section it was a very early draw as
Andrew Tang repeated the position as
white against leavon aronian and there
we see they we Maurice before we even
sat down that game was like in in the
history books as uh Andrew made a quick
draw Maurice welcome welcome I mean
usually do you're always on the show
like what we miss you yeah it's funny
being here new studio I see the lights I
feel like lights are bouncing all off my
head and stuff in the great studio is
everywhere but I'm happy to be here
great to be here with Karina as
well and looking at Christian looking
like a boss isn't he look like a boss or
like a weatherman whichever way you want
to put it I would say boss I mean I'm
loving it I'm loving this uh new setup
what are you doing what's going on in
mauce World nice and retired and do no
I'm busy as ever man busy as ever I'm
doing chessable courses I just finished
my second course uh the Dark Forest
course rampaging Rooks uh just came out
I'm proud about that one rampaging yes
indeed and I also did uh I also finished
two books books are coming out on April
2nd both books both companies had no
clue so they fixed April 2nd as the date
so doing stuff man staying busy so what
are the books about my one book is a
children's book that's about my life
it's a story book with actual drawings
every page for young readers little
Maurice learning chess no it's just
about my My Life as a youngster learning
chess first in Jamaica then in New York
then becoming eventually a Grandmaster
wow for so if you got your little kids
who we want to tell a story about that's
one and the other one is really the
metaphoric connection between chess and
life Gary did a book that's similar many
years ago how life imitates chess right
so it's that kind of book but just more
my Twist on the story on that concept
fantastic wow when you said I'm retired
I was like imagining a life in Miami but
then you said not really and now you are
busy you I've been super busy I've been
traveling a lot as well uh the last four
months I've been to 11 countries so it's
it's definitely not the quiet life wow
it's been it's been fun that's what I
can say dude we have some incredible
games going on you just came into stud
terrible timing on your part because
check out this game of Ray Robson and
give us your Insight Ray with the Rook
lift you you know you kind of see that
stuff when the when you're attacking the
king not when it's like this but check
this out Mishra he's just playing all
the moves like this was appropriate he
knows what he's doing and now check out
this La next move by Ray you know it's
preparation when in this chaotic
position they play a move like H4 like
what what does this remind you of your
practice I us like this all the time not
let me tell you watching watching this
kind of Chess everything unmowed Pawn
structure for black what pawn structure
come on and coordination of the pieces
who organizes your pieces like this I
mean this looks like chess 960 like you
know fish random this this is absolute
chaos
on the board nobody could guess and then
the engine says it's all zeros zeros
baby joking what are you talking about
this is amazing and I got to say I did
an I did an article on ABI Manu when he
was not yet a GM and he was trying to
become a GM and uh and I talked to his
family the dedication that they had to
chess ever since he was a young boy I
mean he was learning chess as a
three-year-old and he was studying chess
hours a day as a six-year-old wow hours
and hours he is it's an extraordinary
family story not just the individual
story but him his dad his mom the
commitment with his sister as well
there're some simply a brilliant family
but the work that they've put in and now
you're seeing it come to fruition
14-year-old leading the US Championship
hello what I mean it's it's extraord and
after every game they he doesn't go rest
he reviews the game and
improved Concepts ideas what you could
have done better he's always about
improving I love his mindset he may not
win this Championship maybe not be ready
yet it say dve
he what are you talking about but the
attitude is there this is a champion in
the making I mean I can already uh feel
the enthusiasm coming back you probably
watch our shows right now going to a
different country every single time but
do you miss being here in the studio
with us you know I miss hanging out more
than anything else I mean the crew is so
fantastic you all Yasser of course
whenever we get we've been we've been
OG's for a while yeah I mean it's been
it's been World Championship matches
we're going back
mid90s we've done commentary I've never
worked with Kate and I had the pleasure
so that I do miss but I have to say what
I'm doing now I'm having a lot of fun
I'm just I'm just challenges it's yeah
it's it's not just a new challenge it's
just uh I get to travel I get to to
write I've always wanted to create
content I've been able to do that I've
do the chessable courses so that content
I'm I've been sitting on content for
years and I finally get the opportunity
to put it out there and now I'm super
excited that the world gets to see that
and I do my corporate speeches still in
the like but uh it's a different world
it's a different kind you tell this
wonderful story the other day at dinner
that uh you were composing a study and
you were you knew that you were going to
meet Dr John nun one of the great
problem studiers so it's like oh I'm
going to tease him with my latest study
tell the audience what yeah that's the
kind of stuff too that I've gotten into
I've been composing you i' be a puzzle
composer I've been composing quite a bit
and I always like to make grandm suffer
that's that's my key job I show you a
study said okay try to solve this as a
player myself former player and and and
a
Grandmaster but I showed one to Dr nun
that had Fiddler struggling and the GMS
in the studio like Maurice get out of
here with this study and I showed none
and within a minute he said very very
interesting maybe I should try this move
oh there's a good defense though uh
let's let's do this and this and this
and this and this and this and this and
this bam entire solution in front of me
I like this cute study
though blew up my study B so I had to go
back and get harder ones I got some
harder ones for John yeah Dr nun is
quite quite the player quite the study
Sol a let's talk about the US champion
look what we got I want to ask you about
one player for the first couple of
rounds prime time has been Hans tell us
about your reaction to his games that
crazy I don't even remember how he
called it the triple
shift triple twist he did triple twist
did you see that with one second I did
see it I did see it one second left on
the clock and there we have I mean the
the chest piece for itself right
yeah Hans Hans looks like a mad genius
when he's playing you don't know if he's
if he's serious if he's pulling your
tail the things that he says mo mo
moment it looks like he's suffering like
right now in in agony and then in the
next moment he's super cool and he he
looks almost sometimes like he wants to
just reach over and punch the guy in the
face right like he's just got that that
attitude about him and those eyes I mean
those those eyes those eyebrows he's got
the the look of of a potential mad
scientist but he's playing chess he's
here to play chess and the pressure
that's on him given the history of what
has happened to him it's insane for a
young person like this to have to deal
with everything that he's gone through
and then there's the love him or hate
him more people in the hate category
than the love but he's a story for chess
right now and everybody hate him you
still have to watch him you your your
eyes are transfixed as what is going to
happen next and what is really happening
I don't know how you play against them
frankly I mean you're sitting there
people having wondering is there
something nefarious going on it's it's
an incredible tale to be sure but we're
watching in the Chess World exactly uh
back to the chess uh quickly Mishra has
not moved since Ray Robson played H4
Mishra did everything he moved his King
all the way from uh F7 back over to the
queen site now he's tanked your your
kneejerk uh would you he just played the
move Queen d8 by the way he he did just
play the move queen d8 that just got
we've been talking about his really
strong preparation but he spent 20
minutes for the last move so he's
probably out of preparation now Sur that
was a surprise for him that move I
before I walked in here I was talking to
VAR in the back and he was showing me
this we were both just like mesmerized
yeah flabbergasted what is this this is
not chess this oh you didn't analy this
position yeah right how do you play
chess like this and play quickly at that
and the lack of coordination with the
black pieces white looks normal right
like white looks like a position but
then you have these crazy pieces that
have just land these especially the pawn
structure but you look at the black
pieces and they look silly right but
there's a lot of them there is there's a
lot of them and and so the suggested
move was Queen to B4 was an alternative
to Queen to d8 and this move going after
the pawn potentially creating a couple
of passers that you could be dynamic
with as well how how do you play this
move when your king side looks like
stuff's going to happen to it any second
and if you drop the G Pawn somehow then
the H Pawn is prepped and to move on the
board you have to you have to do
something like Rook F7 right now for
white go for the Knight and then the
position absolutely Goes Bananas you
take on B2 you take my knight I go A3 A2
and try to get a queen right on the
board but how do you calculate exact and
so when when that was the choice between
this move Queen B4 or queen d8 I said
how do you play Queen B4 like how do you
do it you pick your hand up and say
forget about the other side of the board
I'm just going to go straight all in and
you do your worst especially with a rook
landing on the seventh ring and I just
couldn't believe he would play Queen B4
in that position and the fact that he
played Queen d8 seems to be much more
logical keep the queen in the sector and
fight it out duke it out with the
connected pieces he now has A3
potentially uh if the Rook leaves to
create a pass Pawn The Rook goes to the
seventh for example he can play for A3
and then probably push the C Pawn but
check it out I think I Now understand H4
I Now understand H4 check it out give me
your queen your queen slides over let's
go give me your queen I can also go to
E7 by the way I understand but I kind of
thought you want you want to run yes you
want more and let's say you go here
let's say we got and now I'm really
happy I got my Pawn on H4 exactly you
got a runner I got a runner I mean I
don't I don't know how far it's going up
but it doesn't look like it's going to
fly down but you got two passers as well
right but I really wanted to get your
opinion on the laner Dominguez versus
darish game bring me on when all these
easy positions no no no no no I got the
wrong sorry analyze what what is this
one and we left it check this out are
you ready for the this is this was crazy
this was crazy so Kate asked a very
normal question here the last move by
darush was Knight D4 to F5 she asked
Christian Christian what about Queen of3
I want to win back my peace well
Christian said you can have it like you
just you just went Queen like what what
and the whole point was if you do take
it now you're not checkmating Black's
King and there's always this King H7
King G6 and it's all good normal chess
right normal chess every mov and then
Christenson Christensen Christian said
well what about Rook A3 and Rook F3 and
we were all enthusiastic and it's almost
double triple zeros well you know what I
have to do uh you know what that's about
and by the way lener has been thinking
for 35 minutes it's a it's a big thing
big decision right I think this is
precisely the kind of position that you
want lanir to be in if you're his
opponent if you're not lost right yeah
that's very important because you know
lanir is going to sit there and think
for a while and think more and he's
going to tank and tank the problem is
he's really good exactly and he'll come
up with moves if there's a good move
he'll probably find it right so they're
only what it looks like on move 18 what
is his time situation right now you're
not going to believe this we've been
doing this for decades but you're not
going to believe this but laner had 1
hour and 32 minutes after 18 moves
Dominguez the time trouble king of time
trouble now he's back to 54 minutes this
is a normal back to the normal Z leard
can't change his resp that easily sorry
that the world has been restored that's
that's what we would expect as we get
from him but this is a wild position
it's interesting that it's only wild
because he sacked on G5 right right I
mean it's that was the earli that's the
main point the fact the fact is it was
already a sharped position to begin with
but the sacrifice followed by this
bishop D5 genius idea right followed by
this and now you just want to know
what's actually going on one of the
facts when you're down material that's
why we brought you onto the show oh yeah
sure I can illuminate it all the
variations and it's like this position
is insane and I think they're they're
going to take some time trying to figure
this out okay last one then please
Wesley so Wesley so versus this was more
normal this was a lot more normal I
thought yeah it's it's a pawn sack you
can you can sack a pawn in in the
structure I think before this when
Knight D5 happened that was the the real
moment right here because after cck
Wesley had to make a decision here
because he in tuned his own Bishop with
this Mo this exact moment in time
coming under attack so this move e3s
your bishop and as you go back to win
your material you have to accept the
fractured structure for your King right
and now this one is not one of those
it's totally unmowed insane we can't
tell exactly what's going on positions
it's more like your king is weak back
both kings are weak and can black
untangle and what you're doing now is
just searching for moves how does black
untangle because if black untangles then
it's plus plus a pawn okay you might get
give it back soon but will you have the
time and Wesley's gonna try to make sure
that Rook on h8 stays on h8 never comes
into the game and if if that happens
then white will win the game
fantastic Maurice don't be a stranger
come come come often come of come often
is what I want to say and good luck with
all your projects your chessable courses
don't tell me that they're coming out
soon right the
the chess well the the last one the Dark
Forest rampaging Rooks landed on Monday
so it's out people can go check it out
absolutely I'm very proud of the content
there for those who don't know what it's
about what the Dark Forest is it's based
on a quote that you know well exactly
mik tal you must take your opponent into
a deep dark Forest where 2 plus 2 equals
5 and the way out is only wide enough
for one and this is the kind of Chess I
like seeing that we see on the board
right now we're in the dark Forest so
the it's it's really about material
imbalances but not just basic material
imbalance but severe material imbalances
Rooks beating Queens bishop and two
miners beating queen or two or two Rooks
double exchange sacrifices and the like
so it's crazy chess all the positions
look like the ones we've seen so far
just wild chess but then I break it down
and say what are the factors that make
you able to go into the dark forest and
feel comfortable wow so that's the fun
one and of course uh more coming soon
the second one will be out in December
is what they're looking at and other
courses as well coming out in other
words you've been studying my
games I don't think any I think
any sneak it in there me you hey I'll
pay you a little extra if you get a y
game in there
you I don't think any dark Mars games in
there for you yes but it's it's been a
fun been a fun ride thank you for uh
joining us Maurice and let's just take a
quick look at the pairings starting with
the women Cate so we have